salt is Germany's northernmost island
and its most luxurious two real estate
developers of Eustace Mouse has a house
here good morning good morning my name's
Ralph Eustace mouse and I live here on
Zoot
let me show you my house igano my main
house tigon inside it's bright and airy
the house boasts beautiful views of the
surrounding landscape and use
Jesus house happy conceived I designed
this house because it has a really nice
view of the sand dunes it's a bit like
Long Island the views best enjoyed from
my larger hunting and even from my
knowledge ah
from here Ralph looks out over Germany's
only shifting sand you look for this
this is luxury for me the view the peace
and quiet you're so very close to nature
here I think it's great the house itself
is understated in its design it's real
luxury lies in its location by the way
this is a typical Dutch door it's best
not to gossip about what is or anything
else here costs come here of the in
people pay up to 40,000 euros per square
metre for homes on the island
what a knock me down moon flicker the
house has an estimated value of around
seven million euros it features two
living rooms and four bedrooms ideal for
hosting visitors who are keen on a
getaway break-ins ort
other decrease ahave the kitchen was
built by my carpenter the same guy who
built the whole house highlight it's one
of the highlights is this huge gas oven
made by a company called biking in the
US the whole unit costs over 20,000
euros do you think that cyanide had over
you got some taste housing or will cost
it Bob there's little cooking done here
of Health eustress Mouse doesn't
actually live here his actual home is in
Hamburg
the time he spends insult is all about
pursuing his passions classic cars for
instance but why is land on silt so
expensive new property here has to be
built on the site of a former house
building can only take place on land
that's already seen construction fad
sent property prices skyrocketing an
advantage for the islands residents who
don't have to worry about the natural
surroundings being ruined